Carissa congratulations another game
another Victory and in what fashion uh
this victory was just uh very very
dominant in an explosive game take us
through the critical moments it felt
like by the way you almost got a winning
position out of the opening did you feel
the same
way yeah so um I know Italia played
Bishop D7 in round one I think um and I
briefly checked it and it just didn't
look very good because white can sort of
transposed to a an English attack like a
really good English attack um but it
just felt like she wasn't quite sure
what to do against this setup um it's
just like kind of awkward for black if
you know she plays E5 and Bishop E6 so
she just kind of like wasted a Tempo
yeah with Bishop D7 yeah I think this
like Knight takes D4 plan wasn't good
and then after that she was trying to oh
after
the engine was saying close to plus
three Advantage for you it it was
absolutely uh crazy the evaluation yeah
I didn't I didn't realize
um yeah I don't know maybe I just can't
evaluate Sicilian super well or
something nobody can because we didn't
think it's
that we thought it's maybe plus one
something along those lines but not
completely uh winning and you conducted
the attack I have to say admirably
because you never never leted your
opponent back into the game maybe the
only opportunity she had was to try for
he takes D5 just take the piece and hope
that she's not getting checkmated what
were the variations that you were
calculating right
now yeah so I definitely felt he takes
D5 was critical um so obviously I take
back and then black has a choice between
yeah Bishop B5 Bishop B7 and then I
think
here
um I mean I'm kind of I was debating
between like Rick e one Queen E4 and
Bishop D2 sort of cuz I think like one
plus is that the bishop is sort of
Awkward on B5 um and like once I snag
this B4 pawn it could easily end up
trapped there MH mhm because of like
these sort of like C4 ideas A4 ideas so
do
stuff yeah I felt practically this was
quite good for me um and I also felt
that she wouldn't go for it just cuz you
know it looks really scary for black and
I think she also was running a bit low
on time at this point and there are
still like a lot of moves to go until
move 40 yeah this was move 15 and she
only had 30 minutes on the clock
definitely a lot of decisions on the
horizon for her as well and uh she did
play Knight to C5 but after this you're
just opening absolutely every single
Avenue towards her King and that comes
with devastating
consequences and I have have to say I
mean the end position Bishop to C4 and
Rook to d8 if you move the queen Rook to
G1 is a mate it's such a sad position
did you feel at all bad for your
opponent or there's no such feelings in
a game of chess in a competition such as
this one I honestly thought that it was
just like really geometrically nice
which is why I played Bishop C4 instead
of like Rook takes D7 um and I think it
would be like a cute checkm if she
played like Queen C5 I take on fa8 and
then Rick G1 yes uh yeah yes no I
thought this was super nice
um I did feel a little bad cuz you know
tal and I are uh friends but I think it
was a nice game and usually I try to
separate those feelings a bit CU it like
affects my game so yeah well Karissa
things are going swimmingly for uh you
up to this point congratulations still a
few games to go but you're in a good
spot to F for that National Championship
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you and uh our congratulations as
well